but we begin this morning with President
Trump arriving in France for the start
of the g7 summit Air Force One actually
just landing mr. Trump may get an icy
reception when he meets with the leaders
of Canada France Germany Italy Japan and
the United Kingdom
his arrival also comes as Iran and North
Korea make new claims about test firing
missiles and after major stock indexes
in the u.s. fell sharply on Friday the
Dow lost more than 600 points after
China announced retaliatory tariffs on
billions of dollars of US goods
president Trump fired back on Twitter by
increasing tariffs already placed on
China and for those scheduled to be
imposed on September 1st Paula Reid is
traveling with the president at the
summit in abeyance in south southwestern
France Paulo good morning good morning
Dina historically this event has been a
symbol of international cooperation but
today these leaders are divided on
pretty much every issue from Iran to
trade and president Trump arrives here
in France in an increasingly isolated
position just at a time when he could
use some international support for his
trade war with China China is not even
part of the g7 but it is expected to
dominate the conversation at this year's
summit after the world's two largest
economies dramatically escalated their
ongoing trade war China's Bank Boris on
Friday China unveiled retaliatory
tariffs on roughly 75 billion dollars
worth of u.s. goods
President Trump responded by announcing
he would increase existing tariffs
earlier in the day he ordered US
companies to find alternatives to
manufacturing goods in China encouraging
them to move production to the US the
National Retail Federation released a
statement saying it is unrealistic for
American retailers to move out of the
world's second-largest economy as 95
percent of the world's consumers live
outside our borders the president fired
back I have the absolute right to do
that
we'll see how that goes but I have the
absolute right president Trump has
repeatedly tried to deflect blame for
any u.s. economic turmoil to Federal
Reserve Chairman Jerome Powell no I'm
not happy with Jay Powell I don't think
he's doing a good job at all I don't
think he's much of a chess player in a
speech Friday Powell highlighted the
feds limited power saying setting trade
policy is the business of Congress and
the administration not that of the Fed
president Trump responded tweeting my
only question is who is our bigger enemy
Jay Powell or Chairman XI last year's g7
became six against one as captured in
this photo president Trump refused to
sign the traditional agreement at the
end of the summit and left early amid
disputes over trade to manage
expectations this year the leaders are
not expected to someone a joint
agreement at the end of the summit but
they are expected to engage in
discussions about Iran
the global economy and even whether
Russia should get to rejoin the group
after being kicked out in 2014 over the
annexation of Crimea president Trump's
first meeting will be with Britain's new
prime minister Boris Johnson tomorrow
morning Jeff
okay Paula thank you very much